joining us right now our friend from
ESPN and just to get his thoughts before
we take your phone calls and then the
NBCSN show begins with Peter King Joe
clout and Pat McAfee bill Barnwell back
here in the Rich Eisen show how are you
bill hey guys how's it going I'm fine
the headliner last night you have the
floor what do you got for me what do you
think I I think it's the Justin love
trade right or so yeah the great excuse
me Justin Herbert Jordan listen first
names confused
Jordan love Trey because everything else
kind of went when we expected like
there's a lot of logic no crazy trades
I think the Jordan love trades and what
it means for Aaron Rodgers creature in
Green Bay is the most interesting thing
coming out of day one of the draft
I can't wait to unless you know the
answer I'll ask you before Peter King
did who called Aaron somebody had to
call him last night I mean you have to
hope that somebody called Aaron Rodgers
at least hopefully that they heard about
at least a couple minutes before the
pick was actually made but I mean you
know Aaron Rodgers with Aaron Rodgers
and at the end of the day whether you
told him in advance whether you called
him whether you didn't call him you have
to figure he's not going to be happy
about that
well again he's he's not concerned for
his job right now at all and I'm sure
he's not concerned for his job period
because if the Packers do want to move
on from a 38 year old Aaron Rodgers
there was a market for people that age
in Phillip Rivers okay and I would
prefer to say Rodgers will be much more
physically fit and prone and then then
Phillip somebody will take Aaron Rodgers
at age 38 so his career is not in
jeopardy it's it's just he's been
waiting since 2011 to get a first-round
pick on the offensive side of the ball
and they finally give one and it's right
after he worked whatever magic he was
able to work to get this team into a
position to compete for the conference
championship and they draft somebody
that does not give them in the first for
the first round pick a better shot at
winning next year's NFC this year's NFC
championship at all
I don't know here's what I would say
think about Aaron Rodgers recent past
right this is a guy well we know he has
injury issues a couple years ago it
really sank their season losing Aaron
Rodgers for six or eight weeks if you
have Jordan up in the long term
obviously you're molding him to be your
quarterback to the future there's plenty
of time for that it's two years before
the Packers can realistically for cap
reason to move on from Aaron Rodgers but
that does give you a guy in case Rogers
gets hurt who filled it now do you need
to use a first-round pick to get that
guy no but I do think it helps a little
bit in the short term and then this is a
draft that we know is incredibly teeth
with wide receiver talent even after how
many guys five six have taken in the
first round yesterday so the Packers can
still get a receiver at 62 it's really
think that the third to last tick of the
second round they can still get a guy
who should be able to help that offense
in 2020 I wasn't gonna be as good as
someone you know like a like a Justin
Jefferson or my friends I you know but
those guys weren't on the board so maybe
if the Packer said hey we were gonna
take a white out the once we kind of had
our guys off the board that next tier of
white out is a guy we think we can get
in the second round yeah yes and I said
minutes ago that they can absolutely
come away at the end of the night with
starters that can significantly
contribute this fall but it's just again
the the message that that's been and
even though I know go to constant and
the rest of the crew this is a lot of
what Ted Thompson was doing for years
it's just all builds up it all builds up
and I really would love to get his inner
thoughts at some point he he will be in
front of a microphone and we will find
out but okay so outside of that give me
a give me a peck that you thought that's
chef's kiss what a great opportunity for
this team in this kid from where they
were able to draft him can I give you
one that I think kind of went underneath
the radar oh please I I really like
Jerry duty to the Broncos at 15 I mean
no hay Trulock is not a guy who I think
we have a lot of confidence and as a
franchise quarterback for both those
guys so I think with Jerry duty coming
in he doesn't have to be the top guy
because Cameron Sutton is a awesome
football player you have the NOAA fan
coming in for a second year usually your
tight ends get that second year boost
Melvin Gordon's in a play role in the
passing game this guy's gonna get
one-on-one coverage every single time
he's on the football field I think he's
a guy who can beat one-on-one coverage
and for Trulock I mean this is great you
have all these weapons for a guy who we
don't know anything about at this point
five starts so far you know we're gonna
get to know pretty quick whether he's
the guy or not because there's nothing
he could ask for he has a great pass
catching running back he has a great
pair of wide receiver he has a very
promising tight end he has the weapons
that usually it takes a quarterback two
or three years to kind of a mess so I
think it's just an interesting fit I
think a guy who you know it's gonna be
in a better opportunity to succeed than
it might seem right now given his
quarterback situation what do you think
of the Raiders having their choice of
all receivers and they go rugs I mean I
appreciate the homage to out Davis I
think it's an exciting thing I just I
didn't get it because you have terribly
the grandparents might not be under
contract for very long but you have a
guy who was a down field threat already
you kind of want that intermediate guy
the guy who was going to be the Antonio
Brown for that office and you know Henry
rugs I think is a very promise receiver
but he's not really that guy so you know
I look at that elephant to look at what
with direct heart as well
he's typically on a guy who lost for the
ball downfield on much one's got the
ball of his hands quickly he wants to
you know I get the body
accurately it was very good at that so
you know I think the challenge there but
I questioned the fit in that office
unless the offensive scheme and hey the
quarterback also possibly changes oh
gosh
so what about the Giants and Andrew
Thomas being the first tackle taken on
the board I think we heard a lot about
Andrew Thomas over the course of this
draft period and I think every team had
their own personal preference in terms
of which tackle they wanted but enter
Thomas I think when he you know Greg
mock drafts we talked to people in the
league there are a lot of people who
thought he was the best tackle in the
NFL and I think for the Giants it's a
really good opportunity because not only
can you have him start on the right side
he's a guy who I think a lot of people
thought could be a left tackle in the
long run so now Nate soldiers feature
with the team is uncertainty has been
pretty disappointing his first two
seasons with the Giants he could be cut
this
season at a post June 1st release they
could wait until next year give him one
more season but I think Thomas is a guy
were you you feel pretty confident he
can play both tackle spots which you
know maybe not maybe would not have been
the case for every single one of these
tops four tackles so I think the Giants
are doing the right stuff to support
their offensive infrastructure and
support Daniel Jones and I think at the
end of the day if you think he's your
guy keep your stay at four pick your guy
get your tackle and then hope he could
be a left tackle in the future bill
Barnwell here on the Rich Eisen show the
Browns have to be happy with Jedrek
wills right I mean in the the Cardinals
getting Isaiah Simmons that is just
gonna be a fun fun and to put on on a
level before Patrick Peterson right and
behind Chandler Jones what a what a what
a beautiful piece that is for for
Arizona when you agree I mean yeah could
you imagine heading into this offseason
you would tell a Cardinals fan you're
gonna get Isiah Simmons and DeAndre
Hopkins I mean you know that they would
have they would have been as happy as
the kids very looked in his palatial
estate in Arizona last night if he told
them that before the offseason I think
that's an awesome awesome fit for that
team even what they need every every
fantasy football player every daily
fantasy football player has spent the
last two years starting tight ends
against the Cardinals planner how bad
they are washed Willy had a monster game
against the Cardinals in fantasy
football last year so to get a guy who
you know and I say it Simmons who can
guard tight ends you can play safeties
and play linebacker such an exciting fit
and the Browns I mean everything they
did this offseason tells me hey we're
gonna evaluate Baker Mayfield we're
going to know by the end of the year
whether he is our guy or not get Jedrek
we'll say one tackle spot Jack Conklin
the play the other tackle spot yeah toss
Hooper I mean Baker Mayfield is
everything a quarterback could want so
at this point you know it's going to be
you know 2020 or bust for Baker Mayfield
in terms of evaluating what his future
looks like
as Browns quarter yeah new coach right
Odell if he wasn't traded by last night
he's not going anywhere you know and
then you know Jarvis Landry
he comes back healthy from his surgery
you just mentioned you know and joke
who's gonna be part of the two tight end
one would believe right
Karim hunt Nick Chubb coming off of an
incredible season you just got the
offensive line shore and shored up a
little bit
the defense hasn't really lost
appreciably very much that's it this is
it right for Baker we're the let's put
it this way the Browns are better set up
to evaluate Baker than the Jets are even
though they got backed in last night
with Sam Donald wouldn't you think of
course they are I mean they did more
during the offseason to add talent to
their Arashi but just had a lot of death
there's a lot of you know they added
some pretty mediocre offensive linemen I
like the Rashad Airmen signing but he's
a second third white out realistically I
mean they're still a team that needs a
number-one wideout that needs a a tight
end who is effective and consistently
available to play which has not been the
case and what pacaya Becton I think he's
an awfully talented player I mean I
loved as bad as that is one of the stars
of the draft for me but a guy who I
think is still you know you have to keep
him in shape and I think they can do
that I think he's someone who's you know
I was motivated and played well in
college and and has great footwork
obviously had that great 40 but you know
this is a team that has really struggled
to develop offensive linemen over the
past decade or so some types of Turkish
or Ferguson Nick Mangold class so
candidate up back tenant to a top-tier
left tackle and can he be that guy from
day one because that's what sam Donald
needs at this point bill Barnwell a few
more minutes left with ESPN senior
writer and the host of the bill Barnwell
show podcast right here on the Rich
Eisen show what did you make of the
Eagles evaluation at the wide receiver
position they don't go just in Jefferson
they don't go I youth they go jail and
rhaegar from TCU what do you think of
that move yeah he kind of seems like
he's gonna be the replacement for the
Sean Jackson in 2021 and kind of the
insurance policy if the Sean Jackson is
not 100 percent for a chunk of time in
2020 which we know is a possibility they
really needed to add speed you know it
makes sense they focus on that I think
it speaks to the reality that they still
have some faith in a JJ arc they go
right side and all Sean Jeffrey because
I seem like I say go wife I was going to
be the long-term replacement for Jeffrey
we know Jeffrey's not 100% Ortega
Whiteside really struggled last year so
you know I think does make sense given
what they needed in the short term
sort of how they want to configure that
Ross long-term is you know your Carson
Wentz's and your other players from
their previous job classes get more
expensive they have to kind of get cheap
somewhere and so I think wide receiver
without they go light side and with
raker are going to be the two spots
where they are willing to get those kind
of rookie receivers playing meaningful
roles as recently as Australia Sooners
2021 and the Vikings use the pick they
they got in sending away Stefon Diggs
for Justin Jefferson they've got to be
ecstatic ecstatic over them you have to
be thrilled right if you could make that
trade you know on that day for the
Vikings and know hey we're gonna get
just interesting without having to trade
up
I think that's an absolute victory for
what the Vikings would have wanted you
come into this draft you kind of figure
they're gonna go wide receiver and
cornerback just because they need a wide
out and Mike Zimmer takes cornerbacks
and years where there's cornerback depth
chart is full let alone when it's pretty
empty as it is right now so you know
getting Jeff Gladney getting Justin
Jefferson I think is exactly what they
would have hoped for heading into the
draft I think Justin Jefferson can be an
impact player from day one they're not
gonna throw the ball a ton I think they
want to be a run first team i summers
always said that and I think they're
going to run the ball a little more
frequently than they have in years past
but I think Justin Jefferson is such a
great player that you know he can make
an impact if he's playing 2025 snaps per
game right and and then I'll ask the
question some Chargers fans are probably
thinking about was it worth trading back
into the first round to get Kenneth
Murray is he that good I mean it's a
great football player but at the end of
the day you look at history those traits
lists don't work I mean time after time
after time when you trade into the first
round give up a two and a three for a
player who's not a quarterback or a guy
who's not at a a critical position those
moves not always but almost always tend
to be disappointing I think it's a great
player but look at the Patriots the
Patriots could very viably of said hey
we need an inside linebacker we just
lost Calvin or we just lost Jamie
Collins those guys are you know inside
outside guys they can play a bit of both
but so can Kenneth Murray
let's take Kenneth Murray Bill Belichick
says no let's go down let's get a second
third round pick we can find a guy who's
pretty useful in the second round and
the third round and for however
contended Murray is this Chargers team
now has a major major hole at left
tackle for Justin Herbert a Tyrod Taylor
and without the second or third round
picks no obvious way to fill it mm-hmm
that is significant that's an
interesting one and the choice of clyde
edwards a layer over any other running
back that the Chiefs made what do you
think of that okay so I like it here's
what it reminds me of remember it was
2000 there's 2000 I think the Rams took
Trung candidate in the first time when
they had Marshal's Office and you know
it didn't really work out but it was
such an exciting idea okay let's get you
know another weapon for our offense
let's keep building this offensive core
and we can make this work and he can be
another threat for us I mean the Chiefs
have been able to get by with you know
guys off the street
mediocre writing that's pretty much on a
mediocre running back but a third-round
pick they have not really invested this
much in a running back during the Andy
Reid era so you know I think he's going
to be a guy who rotates and Damian
Williams over the course of his rookie
season but I think a guy who just who do
you cover I think is right you know I
mean this this is the best screen team
and football the Chiefs now you have
Edwards to layer on those screen passes
we can be such a dangerous threat you
have a nice a guy who can beat
linebackers and safety is one on one
when they're in man coverage it's just
there's so many ways for Patrick roblems
to find guys this is gonna make his life
easier
he's gonna be able to dump the ball off
more frequently tourists who are running
back going hey this guy can make people
miss one-on-one he can make big plays
after the catch with his speed and the
Chiefs I mean hunt wants that guy but
Damian Williams was not really that guy
so I think it's a really exciting
opportunity I don't love taking your
running back in the first round but a
good chase it's just a deep team that's
of a talented team but I can not really
fault them for this particular choice so
who is best available tonight sir as we
start focusing on rounds two and three
night - what do you got for me yeah
thank you I think you're looking at the
safeties I think Xavier McKinney and
Antoine Winfield jr. I think two guys
who you know I think we're expected to
go in the first rain especially McKinney
I think the Giants are a team that
really needs safety help the instinct
it's just been a mess for them for so
many years so good see them going for
one of those two guys the Patriots want
to supplement that secondary because who
them going for one of those guys as well
trevone Diggs corner who I think was you
know in a lot of places effectively a
first-round pick and then JK Dobbins I
want to see where he goes could he be a
tick for the Dolphins perhaps at 39 to
sort of learn behind you
and Howard and then be there feature
back from you know your Chi wanted they
know he's a guy who rush you're a big
fan of so I'm hoping he's gonna spot
that I think you can watch him play four
years ago so the quarterbacks that are
gonna go off the board next and your
best guess as to which team takes them
would be which bill good question ah
those I like to think next quarterback
off the board I've been Jacob Eason
maybe you know I think that there's
gonna be that really likes his size his
arm strength
I mean hey the Patriots do it that extra
pick now would it be shocking or out of
the question of thirty seven for them to
go out and draft that guy look at the
Jaguars maybe as a team that could be in
the running for a Nissen perhaps I mean
they added two defensive pieces so they
could look towards the offense um hurts
not I think those yeah the cold what
about as well I think what about hurts
Jalen Hurd so hurts you know I think
there's an interesting bit there I think
it has to be the right team you know
like the three was a Lamar Jackson like
that was the perfect set in a team that
really invested in Lamar Jackson in
terms of their infrastructure and in
terms of their coaching staff so with
Jalen Hurd's be what the Ravens even
consider drafting Jalen Hurd's and
having him be a backup to Lamar Jackson
on the guy who can play a few snaps per
game in a similar sort of role the team
that comes to mind for me as a team that
needs a quarterback a team that's been
very versatile in years past and very
comfortable with different ideas that
what a backup quarterback or another
quarter I could be get Michael Jackson
going back to Kordell Stewart so they
could be a team for me that needs a
quarterback to back up and
Roethlisberger at 49 bill I knew you'd
be the perfect guest to have on the day
after first up a day after the first
round I appreciate it maybe we'll get
you back on early next week we'll talk
about the draft fully all seven rounds
any time really appreciate it that is a
bill barn wall check him out a follow
him on Twitter at bill Barnwell and
follow him whatever I mean that guy
knows everything
that guy's knows everything hey you
watched all the way to the end thanks
for that
watch more right here